London is getting back to work after the
deadly terror attack in the heart of the
city Britain's Prime Minister's
promising stronger anti-terror messages
and measures after seven people were
killed in at least 48 injured she said
enough is enough
CBS News has learned two Americans are
among those hurt one is in critical but
stable condition
three attackers drove a van through
crowds walking over the famous London
Bridge then they got out and started
stabbing people in a busy restaurant
area armed police responded and killed
the attackers since then they've carried
out a series of raids and detained a
group of people looking for connections
to the attackers Elizabeth Palmer is in
central London at the scene of the
attack on London Bridge the nearby
Borough Market area was packed with
visitors out on a Saturday night who ran
for their lives Isis claimed
responsibility for the rampage Elizabeth
good morning good morning
yes I'm standing on London Bridge where
the attack happened it's half opened
again this morning expected to open
fully later today and it's several miles
from the outer East London suburbs where
police have been making arrests in the
last 24 hours directly related to the
attack they say they're looking for
accomplices today's arrests add to more
than a dozen made on Sunday in the area
where one of the attackers is believed
to have lived in London police patrols
have been stepped up backed by a vast
intelligence network that's been
tracking potentially violent radicals in
fact recently the police have been
detaining an average of one person a day
on terrorism-related charges chief
crested a dick but I would just remind
people that we do have literally
thousands in fact tens of thousands of
people who we would regard as a subjects
of interest
on Saturday night it took 8 minutes for
police to shoot the three attackers dead
wearing what turned out to be fake
suicide belts back on the bridge though
victims were fighting for their lives
the police know who the attackers are
but haven't named them this is believed
to be them caught on cell phone video on
the prowl for people to stab just before
they were killed
leaving mayhem in their wake and a trail
of shocked and bleeding victims minutes
before the attack
Brad Meyers on vacation from Florida
took a selfie on the bridge and walked
away then he heard the van mount the
sidewalk but you saw it accelerate yes
definitely saw and heard of it celery
here's the photo he took afterwards
victims and their possessions strewn all
over the road I do think that everyone
needs to see you know what is going on
and what we're up against
Britain's Prime Minister Theresa May
this morning put it into words this was
an attack on London and the United
Kingdom but it was also an attack on the
free world the challenge of course is
what to do to prevent another attack and
whatever strategy the government comes
up with it's going to be controversial
difficult and expensive Gail thank you
Elizabeth Palmer reporting from London